how does regenerative medicine work
today how do you hope it works what's
the hope there yeah yeah how do you make
it happen well today there's a set of
popular approaches so so one is 3D
printing so the idea is I'm going to
make a scaffold of the thing that I want
I'm going to seed it with cells and then
and then there it is right so kind of
direct and then that works for certain
things you can make a bladder that way
or an ear or something like that
um the other the other ideas is some
sort of stem cell transplant into the
ideas if we uh if we put in stem cells
with appropriate factors we can get them
to generate certain kinds of neurons for
certain you know diseases so on all of
those things are good for relatively
simple structures but when you want an
eye or a hand or something else I think
in this Pro you know maybe an unpopular
opinion I think the only hope we have in
any reasonable kind of time frame is to
understand how the thing was motivated
to get made in the first place so what
is it that that made those cells in the
in the beginning create a particular arm
with a particular uh set of sizes and
shapes and number of fingers and all
that and why is it that a salamander can
keep losing theirs and keep regrowing
theirs and a planarian can do the same
even more so to me a kind of ultimate
regenerative medicine was when you can
tell the cells to build whatever it is
you need them to build right and so so
that we can all be like planarian
basically do you have to start at the
very beginning or can you um
do a shortcut okay we're throwing a hand
you already got the whole organism yeah
so here's what we've done right so so
we've we've more or less solved that in
frog so frogs unlike salamanders do not
regenerate their legs as adults and so
so uh We've shown that with a very um uh
kind of simple intervention so what we
do is there's two things you need to uh
you need to have a signal that tells the
cells what to do and then you need some
way of delivering it and so this is work
together with them with David Kaplan and
I should do a disclosure here we have a
company called morpheuticals and
spin-off where we're trying to uh to
address uh regenerate you know limb
regeneration so we've solved it in the
Frog and we're now in trials and mice so
now we're going we're in mammals now and
I can't say anything about how it's
going but the Frog thing is solved so
what you do is um after you have a
little frog Luke Skywalker with every
growing hand yeah basically basically
yeah yeah so what you do is we did it
with legs instead of forearms and what
you do is after amputation normally they
they don't regenerate you put on a
wearable bioreactor so it's this thing
that um that goes on and Dave kaplan's
lab makes these things and inside it's a
it's a very controlled environment it is
a silk gel that carries uh some drugs
for example ION channel drugs and what
you're doing is you're saying to these
cells
you should regrow what normally goes
here so uh that whole thing is on for 24
hours then you take it off you don't
touch the leg again this is really
important because what we're not looking
for is a set of micromanagement you know
printing or controlling the cells we
want to trigger we want to we want to
interact with it early on and then not
touch it again because because we don't
know how to make a frog leg but the Frog
knows how to make a frog leg so 24 hours
18 months of leg growth after that
without us touching it again and after
18 months you get a pretty good leg that
kind of shows this proof of concept that
early on when the cells right after
injury when they're first making a
decision about what they're going to do
you can you can impact them and once
they've decided to make a leg they don't
need you after that they can you know do
their own thing